this morning on the dish restaurant and
nightclub entrepreneur Edie Kane born in
Boston he started his career close to
home working in his family's
neighborhood bar after college he and
his brother Joe bought and renovated an
old diner and that was just the
beginning
Kane had a feel for hospitality and an
inspired eye for design his big night
Entertainment Group now runs 13 venues
from top-rated restaurants to
spectacular nightclubs and even a
high-end bowling alley one of his latest
projects is Boston's explorer tour and
he's bought us dishes from it's French
inspired menu it came good morning
welcome to the dish
tell us what's on this great table a lot
of wonderful things so the company here
is the local cod and there's a saffron
mussel broth classic tune in the SWAT
salad over there with the tuners seared
with fennel the fried cauliflower this
is here with the tahini sauce that's
going to go on top your you have your
mini French onion soup and this is a
French onion soup who love their there
mm-hmm and this fantastic dish here is a
apple and quince crisp which so these
are all kind of great fall dishes yeah
and then the drink that you have there
is my bar manager ian's homage to Twin
Peaks oh my god yeah please thank you in
forming that yes so it's black fig vogue
black tea bourbon and a black syrup that
we make we serve it in a clear tea pot
and we put dry ice in the end so it kind
of spilled over as it's very mysterious
very cool well you know your family
business was this industry you start
with your dad in his bar what was the
biggest takeaway from that time there
that I didn't want to do it and no but I
think you know you don't know when
you're a kid in high school and all your
friends are doing other things and
you're at the bar cleaning in the
mornings and when I went to college I
swore I'd never be in that business oh
come on come on you're the classic Good
Will Hunting I mean you went from you
know mopping floors to Harvard
University
yeah economics major
and when I graduated I shared a little
computer company I had stayed in the
computer company but but in any case I
got back in the business right I have a
wonderful the brother who is a great
mentor to me and he also allowed me to
do the creative things that I'm very
good at and we started our first place
and it was a huge success despite the
fact that I really had no idea what I
was doing yeah we're about to celebrate
30 years there it'll be open 30 years so
that's a pretty good run in the
restaurant business and then I had a
client and he had a big outside venue
and he it was a nightclub 3,000 person
night club and I said oh I can do that I
just felt like it was such a great
opportunity right now and and it was
next level and I had a lot of great
support systems what is the secret to
making a great night club mm-hmm I think
everything centers around like a design
that it's that that that transcends time
like that that that is around for a long
time that feels like it's been there
that makes a person walk through the
door feel and in the nightclub business
feels wonderful and glamorous I love
when they walk through so it's designed
in that hospitality it's the feeling of
safety especially for women women want
to come to a nightclub and feel like oh
this is a safe place and this is a place
I can enjoy myself and really have fun
and not feel like I'm going to get the
salt or you know it's got to be exciting
and glamorous and so I think we do a
good job putting those together wow it's
so much success I'm gonna have you
saying obsession and let me ask you
we're filling your table right now but
if you could fill your table and have
this meal with anyone who would it be
oh it would be my mom for sure my mom
died when I was a kid when I was in my
twenties my first restaurant stars she
died a week after I went oh and I always
thought oh I would really love her to
see what way you know what we've
accomplished at Cain thank you thanks so
much
okay for more on Edie Cain and the dish
you can head to our website at CBS this
morning calm